well I think humor works in this way
it's a you know it not only tells us how
to understand things it tells something
about the limits of our understanding hi
it usually uses incongruity in other
words you you Yuma can't just be
something that's absolutely normal it
has to deviate from the normal and it
uses some incongruity but that
incongruity just can't be anything it
has to be appropriate so let me just
give you some really simple examples
like a riddle you know when is a door
not a door when it's ajar okay we that's
a silly little riddle but we understand
that they that the the the it's you have
this incongruity you have a door that's
not a door you have what the interesting
thing about humor is that in humor you
in logic
something is a or not a in humor it's
both a and not a let's take my cartoon
culture to mind well known quite to man
there's a guy on the phone he's looking
at his rolodex and he's saying no
Thursday's out how about never is never
good for you now let's look at that what
are the two what's the incongruity there
the incongruity is for it wouldn't be
funny if you said if he's saying I don't
want to see you right that's what he is
saying right but he's saying it politely
so the two things that exist what's been
called a cognitive synergy that don't
completely resolve is the message is
rude and the form is polite the message
is rude and the form is polite that's
why the sentence that's why when I did
the cartoon I didn't say no Thursday's
out how about never I say is never good
for you it continues that so you so
you're bringing things together that
don't usually go together and that can't
logically go together
you can't both be polite and rude you
are both in fact being polite and rude
so I think we we delight in that and we
also delight in I mean through jokes we
delight in these synergies these
paradoxes that don't resolve themselves
for example I mean you know but we can
make but we make it funny by
so bringing in the emotional factor of
people for instance it's a paradox to
say this sentence is false but nothing
funny about it right this sentence is
false well that's interesting it's false
but it's true but it's false to make it
funny there's a wonderful Alex Gregory
cartoon from The New Yorker in which to
boss a Hollywood boss and he's saying to
the guy in front of him
Dave I'm not going to lie to you I'm
going to lie to you so you're saying you
have that you know you have that
essential thing now in terms of
incongruity and by appropriate congruity
it's appropriate but it's not completely
appropriate to logic I can do that by
extending the riddle thing the door not
a door you know it's ajar okay everyone
Durst and that but how about how about a
riddle you know like this you know uh
what's grey and comes in a drawer liquid
elephant well now that's not now we've
one of the things as you can see it
along a continuum of incongruity where
where there's some resolution I mean it
wouldn't make sense if I said mayonnaise
that would certainly be incongruous
right but there's still something there
or even taking it further absurdly and
saying why is there only one Eiffel
Tower and the answer because it eats its
young okay now so so that's very very
strength is still something there's
still some attachment we understood if
there was an animal that eats young it
would be maybe alone so the constituents
of humor I mean there's really three
different theories actually when you get
down there's a superiority theory which
Hobbes it was of course a theorist of
power said it's the it's the it's the
sudden glory we feel when we see an
eminence in ourselves compared to an
inferiority in someone else
that guy slipping on a banana peel now a
lot of humor has superiority and a lot
doesn't and you know the holy grail of
humors find the necessary and sufficient
conditions for it well if the necessary
if it was sufficient they have
superiority every time we saw
a homeless person or a beggar we laugh
and we don't so I I think people confuse
the fact that we often have an
aggressive content in humor we're
thinking that it's either necessary you
know or sufficient the thing that does
seem you know then then there's the the
sort of the relief theories of Freud
which is basically that we sort of this
cauldron of desires aggression and
sexuality and humor enables us to
actually sort of subvert the moral
dilemma of aggression by being
distracted by the joke in which is which
either expresses sexuality aggression
and then this is incongruity theory
which says that it's something either
ambiguous that doesn't fit that somehow
is made to fit I think you in a way to
really understand it and not understand
it scientifically but in some
comprehensive way you see that these are
all parts that that go into it
well I think what uniquely suit is is
our ambivalence in the fact that we're
multiple selves and we all have
different agendas you know there's
something called Grice's Maxim's and I
can't remember all of them but basically
they say I do not say what you believe
to be false do not exaggerate you know
be brief be informative and that's good
for a lot of discourses like science and
stuff it's actually quite bad for a lot
of communication with people in which we
don't know what they think and they
don't know what we think and humor is a
way in which we can use ambiguity to
probe ideas and to straightforward
language often leads to some decision
when often the most important thing is
not to it's not to do something but just
stand there interestingly humor you know
versus anger and fear is sort of an
immobilizing response it really tells it
we don't do anything give you an example
of how language works and you know an
ambivalent way between me and my wife
natural conversation we renovated our
house and my wife sorry need I'm very
sloppy so we decided you know what my
studio is going to be outside the house
so a very nice studio was created
outside the house inside the house so I
have my green chair my old green chair
and so my wife says you know now we made
the house so nice why don't we get rid
of that ratty green chair of yours or
you know I said what do you mean I mean
I love this tree I love it sure well if
you like it so much why don't you take
it out to your studio I said I don't
want this nasty thing out there okay
that actually shows our contradictory
feelings but instead of getting into
into locking horns about it we realize
well you know what let's let's negotiate
let's compromise and humor is full of is
full of paradox and our lives are full
of paradox
ah the line between humor and bad taste
is your audience in which in which in
which some people will find everything
offensive and and and and some people
will find nothing offensive but the
truth is that most humor originates in
what would be called bad taste when you
look at the origins of humor and Greek
comedy which followed the tragedy which
was you know very very obscene you know
the satyr plays huge phalluses was you
know people running around you know very
very very very aggressive basically
coming out of a you know drunken rebel
rituals the Feast of Fools the Lord of
misrule Punch and Judy shows all
actually draw on this primitive side of
humour which I talked about before that
it comes out of fear and aggression it's
a way to to negotiate that so they deal
very very strongly with creating
situations that are fearful aggressive
or transgressive so the audience is
important going to a Chris Rock concert
is very different than opening the pages
of The New Yorker the most offensive
thing that ever occurred in the New York
it would seem like the mildest thing at
a Chris Rock concert